[Music]
i'd love to ask you a question that i
think you ask
of i want to say founders reasonably
frequently and i i'm sure i'm going to
get the phrasing wrong but
the question relates to
key
career
decisions and maybe you can
tell me first how you actually ask it
but i would just love to know how you
would answer the question of
absolute key
watershed decisions
in your career if one or two
float to the top of the list
we call them crucible moments at sequoia
crucible moments perfect and my partner
jim gates actually is the one who came
up with that i'm not going to claim
credit uh he deserves credit for the the
phrase
and we apply it to business context by
the way
and
it'll answer your question but i think
it's it's really important for companies
to think about crucible moments because
often they don't even identify them they
don't realize that they face a crucible
decision whether it's geographic
expansion product expansion a key shift
that the business must make and i'm not
talking about pivots where what you try
doesn't work it's it's something really
different at mongodb the decision to
become a cloud business was a crucible
decision at square the decision to build
cache app as a personal
uh individual product rather than an smb
product that was a crucible decision
very difficult to pull off within the
company
but these decisions end up having a huge
bearing on the ultimate outcome of a
company and so do they with careers and
so when i interview somebody for example
i don't focus on you know tell me
everything that happened while you were
at this job tell me why you chose this
job
how did you find this opportunity what
else were you thinking about and what is
it about this particular opportunity
that attracted you why did you go to the
school
and why did you not go to that school
those are the more interesting questions
they're also indisputable because that's
what you actually did you know you can't
tell me that you know what am i good at
oh i'm a perfectionist okay great you
know that's just a glib answer to the
question
so for me the crucible decisions
one of them was to join mckinsey
when i qualified as an actuary i took a
50 pay cut relative to what i would have
been earning as an actuary to join
mckinsey
and i had to pay back the bursary that
i'd gotten from the insurance company so
it was a double whammy financially and
the bursary is effectively a scholarship
college yeah but you have to pay back if
you don't go work for them so the the
deal was that they would pay for my
tuition and i had to work for them for
the same number of years that i studied
to pay off the debt and if i didn't work
for them i literally had to pay them
back every penny and so
so i earned less and had the debt to pay
off i made the same decision when i
joined paypal
so i had
mckinsey was paying for some of my
tuition at stanford and i had to pay
them back
and what i was getting i still have my
offer letter elon recruited me to to
paypal
x.com and i have the signed offer letter
still on my door and uh i got 80 000
that was my salary when i finished
my mba in 2000 and it was less than
mckinsey was going to pay me
and i had to pay mckinsey back
and then the third one was joining
sequoia and those are the three key
career decisions
you